if you want to be a good guy you maybe
say like look I can't do this anymore
but bro look I've seen you I can tell
your energy and you're not gonna do that
you're not a good guy yeah
all right what's up guys his dick took
21 for you so been messing around with
this girl for the past couple of weeks
with her one night after we went to the
bars after school
um went back to her place she was with
her boyfriend that night too oh but he
was in her room and I was kind of on the
couch with her oh boy so the catch is
that she does have a boyfriend he knows
me I know him but we're not friends like
that I think she likes me more than I
thought so ever since that night we've
been hanging out kind of on the low
um pretty much doing everything when it
comes to hooking up she's asked me to
hold it while I even pee so oh God
pretty bizarre we've done the horizontal
Mamba a couple of times but she started
crying after and stopped it short
because she claims she feel guilty so if
you hold your dick when you claims she
isn't cheating and her boyfriend doesn't
treat her right but she keeps going back
to him even though she will talk to me
as well so it's calmed down a bit but
the question I have for you guys is do I
keep talking to her or do I kind of just
leave her alone and let the situation
play out oh this is a night nightmare
dude this is a dude yeah bring up the
conversation and tell you're not gonna
see anymore when she's holding your
penis while you're peeing be like
also what do you do with your hands if
she's you never had someone hold your
pee while you're pee or your penis yeah
yeah I've had that yeah yeah
um
so the truth comes out you know my
my agent used to do it
um I
I don't know because in there
um no but yeah I think that that's
absolutely uh uh I mean this is a
[ __ ] Travis this is a debacle right
what's he doing yeah well you know what
he's doing you know what he's doing he's
making trouble no you know what he's
doing being a guy he's being a young guy
yeah yeah but uh it's bad you know it's
bad that's why you're called in right
but uh it's uh man you gotta uh also you
know the guy oh yeah hey you went into
this house and you did it with her yeah
and he was sleeping in the room what are
you doing dude this is you're you know
what dude you're gonna end up dead
that's what this is yeah no that's
you're gonna end up dead so she and then
he's gonna do it yeah definitely I mean
this is absolutely insane I don't know I
know guys get in situations like this
where it's just like yeah man but it
just you know it felt too good
had to had to yeah look I I get it yeah
he's gonna get killed you're right uh
this is the kinds of things people kill
people over oh yeah the two things that
people kill people over are Love and
Money yes and this is about [ __ ] love
when men get like their ego bruises when
they kill people oh dude when you get
your ego bruised over love forget it
dude
us don't say you no not you you said you
you the proverbial you no not it's it's
not that common I'm saying there are
certain [ __ ] though yeah that
haul off okay and can't control their
[ __ ] and they [ __ ] kill you and it
sounds like this guy is one of those
guys he's gonna kill you dude yeah I
mean you're gonna have a fun a [ __ ]
gun talking to you dude I mean this is
just ridiculous dude yeah you're you're
gonna how about this dude you're gonna
die yeah all right so you should call it
off yeah call it off bro also you did
the horizontal Mamba right also anytime
you're doing a horizontal Mamba with
somebody and then they start crying
that's the last
time yeah you can't be doing that that's
the last time dude it's not a good sign
under any circumstance that is not a
good it's like you're doing [ __ ]
don't stand oh
I'll see you later forever
it's been fun don't high-five the guy on
the way up
sorry bro didn't even really know you
like that yeah that was what does he
mean by that didn't I yeah I know I
don't really know him like that he's
kind of my friend but I don't really
know him like that okay what I mean is I
don't really know him like that what I
mean by that is
um I know him but not well enough to not
[ __ ] his girl in his house
I'm the worst guy
uh I don't know he hasn't given any
reason to not
like end it like he's not like I really
like her like she's just yeah she's just
around yeah he's just doing a horizontal
Mamba bro so then if that's all it is
absolutely stop it if you if you really
love her though and you want to be like
with her yeah now look still you're
gonna end up dead but try to [ __ ] you
know be like look I want to be with you
yes gonna end up dead anyway yeah but
you know at least go out with love right
what you could also say if you really do
like her say this boyfriend you
obviously not not that into him yeah why
don't you break up with him and we can
date yeah instead of cheating on him why
don't you be with me and cheat on me
because that's gonna happen no well no
maybe she's into him maybe she is but
she obviously is feeling well look she's
conflicted you need to get it right with
her you need to talk with her yes and
say what's going on if you don't want to
do that then it's within your right to
Just Bounce bro I mean she's the one
with the boyfriend yes you don't really
owe or anything yes and I you know I
mean if you want to be a good guy you
maybe say like look I can't do this
anymore but bro look I've seen you you I
can tell your energy and you're not
gonna do that you're not a good guy yeah
um yeah dude I mean if you want to
change and become a good guy
then these things are on the table right
we know that you're not a good guy so
it's in your best interest just to
Simply end it yeah with her and either
way let me just be totally Frank either
way your life's gonna end very soon
you're going to be you're gonna be
killed yeah either way dude you're gonna
have guns talking to you yeah yeah I
mean they're just gonna [ __ ]
yeah pick pick those [ __ ] you know
those ones with just a pick pick here's
what you're all going to be having a
conversation if you love your friends
and family stay away from them yeah
because they might catch a stray bullet
yeah dude yeah they didn't want to have
a conversation with some [ __ ] weapons
no right but all of a sudden because of
your love triangle yeah your family's
gonna have a conversation with some
weapons yeah right they didn't want that
right that's why they didn't want the
guy to talk to him that's why he
shouldn't respect them and stay far away
how am I talking to something that's
four pounds right yeah right because
because the only thing that's four
pounds is a baby and they don't
understand English and how to speak it
oh look a Glock is four pounds too Pat
right in his face okay
do you understand what I'm saying I mean
I do yeah I'm hanging on by a thread
understanding because this guy is
basically making the other guy think an
obsessive thought which is I really
don't want to have to [ __ ] pull out
something from my draw that weighs four
pounds
why are you getting hung up on the
weight of the thing it's just a [ __ ]
nice way to talk about it then okay dude
a gun's four pounds there are there's a
four pound burner you know what I mean
oh okay I don't know you'd sound like
you don't know but I have no idea okay
yeah but it you know if it was four
pounds it's hilarious and I'm very funny
if that is true what's a four pound gun
oh Mill spin beef Jones is what it goes
24 ounces 300
5.8 pounds oh word up
oh okay so then oh how how heavy is a
Glock 19 go ahead right there but the
first one
right there
fully loaded Glock 19.
oh [ __ ] two pounds that doesn't sound
doesn't sound right what what gun is
four pounds just do that wow just want I
want it to fit in I should be right you
know
desert Eagle's four pounds okay so I was
talking about the candidate maneuver
dude I I said Google something and he
didn't do it dude yeah he did oh it is
oh yeah that Desert Eagle bro
you don't want that [ __ ] you don't
want that dry bird coming at you right
speak in your language wow
you don't want that [ __ ] you know
you're yelling
[Laughter]
just [ __ ]
yeah and Eddie's [ __ ]
on
I know you like this part oh and then
that [ __ ] dry bird just coming up
right behind you speaking to you dude
you don't want that right no
nobody wants a massive dry bird behind
them speaking to them oh man I love this
so much and I love you dude and this is
so great but I sure hope I I sure I sure
hope that no [ __ ] four pound dry bird
is behind
Brian the famous last words
the four pound dry Bird yeah all right
[Music]